lori how much of like a childhood dream
come true
is this like liu kang come on man
uh it's a it's a lot of childhood dream
come true
um i mean i owe my kid's self a lot of
allowance money because you know he
spent a lot of quarters on that
arcade game and it's been accruing
interest
for over 30 years you know what i mean
so
um it's a it's a vindication
for him and it's my thanks to that kid
i've stopped
child proofing my brain i want to let
him in
and for people to see this film i want
them to let their kid
childhood self in as well um
and let them live man whether you're
accountants or engineers now or acting
or actually living your dream
let that in a little bit feel that
nostalgia
that's beautiful i love that you know we
know you're always in shape
but this is next level stuff on top of
that
you've got to you know you've got all
the fight choreo all the action to put
into it
what kind of a task was it for you to
actually put in that work
to bring liu kang to the screen
uh i mean that part is always a hundred
percent for me
um to do acting it's never about
for me it's never about getting rich or
or
becoming super famous all those are
um welcome side effects
maybe someday right but for me it's to
tell the story to make more films
um and to stay in shape for a role like
this
i really had to hit the ground running
and already be running because it was
like
uh a marathon at a sprinter's pace i
would have never
gotten to the finish line if i didn't
but for this film i really had to put in
200
because you know my thumb is not really
the area i train the most but for the
this film it really was all the mashing
on the video game system
um playing lukang for three months
before we started
yeah really really took a um
really augmented my calluses on these
guys right on
took a toll on you huh you know it's it
was fun watching you uh
document the journey of making this film
especially seeing you
max louis and joe it's like i couldn't
tell if you guys were doing an action
movie or if you guys were going to start
a boy band together like you look like
you guys are so tight
what was it like getting a chance to get
close to all these people when you were
filming
yeah it felt like we really belonged i
mean stepping on set where you're not
the token asian
where you just feel like yes this is the
world i mean i travel a lot and i see
asians everywhere
um and this is what it's like um and all
the films where i step on set and
you know you're the feature asian i i i
want to make that fleshy i want to break
out of that stereotype and make it my
own
you know but for this film it just we
were
just boys playing around and for that
boy band we
we we stuck around in the neighborhood
it was after wrap we had a
we had a nice dinner at a chinatown and
uh joe to get into character for
sub-zero
wanted to get a six-pack of ice cream
which he wants to demolish all by
himself
so then we walked into an asian grocery
store and
um the clerks there took some photos for
us posing up in the aisles
and that's when mkb started that is our
boy band
uh the single is forthcoming but um
the funny thing is these stories just
roll on and on because months later we
get a
i got fan mail saying my aunt owns that
grocery store in adelaide
and that came out so regretful that she
didn't go to work that day
that's awesome you know you said
something there about
um not being the token agent that really
hits home
you know um growing up
a lot of people didn't get a chance to
see themselves represented let's say
properly on screen unless you were
watching movies that came from
hong kong or korea or japan or india
philippines
right in north america movies we didn't
have that going on now we're at a spot
now
where you can point to a film
and say yeah i can see myself there you
know for young people that are watching
how much of an impact did you want to
make
with not just this film but the roles
that you do in general
i wanted to make an impact where it
doesn't seem like
uh that's the only thing they can hold
on to anymore because the original
mortal kombat was like that for a lot of
asian americans or asian
overseas asians right you don't get
yourself uh
you don't see yourself represented that
much so rob and joe played that role
where it's like oh my god i can be
uh i can be the hero of my own story and
i think everyone
should feel like that i think every man
and woman should feel like
they're they're the master of their
journey
that they're walking on right i think
mortal kombat does that i think things
like uh raya sauria the last dragon
recently i think that does that right
we need to have more of these things
where it actually feels real
where i mean the original mortal kombat
was 95 that was like 23 almost 23 years
ago or something like that
um yeah i don't want to wait another 20
something years for something like that
to happen i want to make more of these
um i'm
on a series called kung fu right now and
same thing as the first primetime series
that features
uh a rich story about an asian family
growing out in america and they confront
all these
trouts and tribulations and it's not
some wild story it's
something that we can all adapt to so
for us to become familiar
to uh everybody uh in the community
that makes us not just other anymore it
makes us familiar and relatable
yeah you know our hearts have been
breaking
um seeing the news and seeing what's
been happening on the news
and watching your speech from the steps
of the vancouver gallery was very
inspiring
you know what was it that had you
that stirred inside you that made you go
i have to choose now to say this
i have to get up in front of these
people right now and speak to them about
what's happening
well it always comes back to one person
my mom like seriously i
i um before i'm checking on my friends
and before i can even call my mom she
calls me telling me
you got to be careful this is happening
and on the news they're attacking elders
and attacking women that's exactly
who my mom is you know what i mean so
um it's a testament to the strength and
courage and love in our community
that whenever i call someone they're
always worrying about others because
that's what we do
right and for me to step up there it's
my ownership of my responsibility
um i i live in vancouver near chinatown
um and right beside chinatown is
downtown east side
it has the highest concentration of
addicts in
all of america right in vancouver
beside a historic chinatown um and
chinatowns has been vandalized recently
in the past year
uh during the pandemic but what i
started to realize that
people don't realize these both these
populations
are marginalized people and they're
acting and reacting
because of fear and we need to call out
that fear and take responsibility and
ownership for it and group together
behind something
and share our stories that's powerful
and we have to we have to say it we have
to act it we have to yell it so loud
that our government actually recognizes
that this is happening
because since the beginning they've been
denying this uh words like hung flu or
flung about like it's nothing this
information was flying all over the
place and
the government was pretending that it's
not happening it is happening
and for us to speak her story to tell
her story to get it out there
it's actually like vaccinating against
racism
because for us to put this out there so
that everybody's aware
as soon as something like that happens
the community can form
a defense can react to it and stop it
from happening again
if you don't tragedies like what
happened atlanta will happen over and
over again and believe me that's
happening
every day so uh like ryan reynolds said
don't don't attack our moms protect
their moms
you know protect women protect our
elders and protect yourselves
right on man speaking the truth as
always ludi
such a pleasure chatting with you
brother yeah carlos
you have a good day man
you